football is the most popular sport in
Sierra Leone in the city of Freetown
there is one very special team meets the
flying start my name nawa Malatya how to
play for Santos last purchasable close I
don't need a partner
[Music]
Mohammed grew up playing football when
he was only 10 years old he stepped on a
landmine and had to have his right leg
amputated and unfortunately Muhammad
isn't alone the saloon flame star
amputee football since now war affected
entities prelada so so did every member
of the Flying Stars has lost limbs as a
result of the violence that occurred
during the civil war in Sierra Leone but
the players don't let their injuries
stop them from getting into the game go
to the usual them questions ready jump
LaRose yamadera paused and a plutonic
one leg hello thank you Mike minima by
thoroughly amenities push for the flames
are fantasy football club president Lena
Pretoria satellizer
third nine starts now well value over
3000 because it seems 12 is zero
research where Galloway - okay country
not welcome the work input get some
countries will level they do let short
short to honest visit and shorty clunky
penalty shootout I'll select empty
normal X out the ability to well church
Church the bus not only is it a
competitive store it is helping them
cope with their injuries and overcome
the stigma that's associated with the
disabled community on a nice control
friend says we need for boosts obscure
gimmick to forget but with more black
and what better way then football
election boy it was an executive of all
like you and I they don't make me do not
see trouble Baker non-oil college
that's not fundamental of the gathering
[Music]
you